there is a massive problem on Twitch
right now and it's putting hundreds of
thousands of kids at risk Bloomberg News
recently released their investigation
that details how predators are using the
platform to exploit children so what
does the investigation tell us and what
is Twitch doing to quell the growing
concerns
[Music]
before we get into it we wanted to give
out a Content warning since this story
does deal with online child abuse if you
or anyone you know has been affected by
this you can find links in the
description of resources that help with
child protection online last week
Bloomberg News published an extensive
report detailing how child Predators
have been using twitch to prey on
children with evidence dating back to
October 2020. since then they have found
that Predators have targeted at least
000 children the article starts off by
recounting a story of two young girls
streaming to a handful of viewers on
Twitch when one viewer asks them to
place the camera on the table so that
their full bodies are in view before
asking them to do handstands and perform
their favorite Tick-Tock dances over the
next 45 minutes this viewer found the
streams of four other young girls on
Twitch and proceeded to follow them but
this isn't fictional this is just one
example of many that a researcher was
able to find in their investigation in
fact over the two years of their study
they found at least
1976 accounts that followed young
children they found this by looking at
twitch profile data as well as
screenshots and videos hundreds of these
accounts were following at least a
thousand kids or more in July of this
year alone these alleged Predators were
finding and Following over 600 kids in a
single day these Predators browse
through twitch looking for new channels
or streams with low viewer accounts and
then they sift through the streams
searching for those who are clearly
invisibly underage a lot of the time
kids will make accounts for fun and go
live to essentially no one without
realizing the potential danger they're
actually putting themselves in because
as the investigation shows these
predatory accounts will go into these
streams and use the chat to coax
children into doing dances or other
sexually exploitive acts at the moment
many large creators on the platform are
just learning about how severe this
problem is uh Bloomberg came out with an
article I haven't read it yet but
apparently there's like some [__]
crazy
there's like actual files on the
platform that like go to like you know
10 view or like one viewer no viewer uh
children streamers and like try to do
feel it to them and stuff like it's just
insane one question you might be asking
is how do they identify these predators
in the first place well Bloomberg
explained that quote the researcher
assembled databases of twitch accounts
by manually identifying live streams of
young people and determining which of
their followers also track other
children one data set represents
predatory users those believed to be
adults targeting children who each
possesses a follower list comprised of
at least 70 kids or young teens the
researcher created a separate data set
of apparent children targeted by these
accounts and reported instances of overt
predation to the ncmec and twitch it's
all pretty disturbing stuff the
researcher even asked to remain
anonymous this was due to Career
concerns being related to this topic the
questions are how has this been able to
happen and what's being done to prevent
it well a lot of the researchers
findings all link back to one problem
that's always persisted on Twitch since
it's currently impossible for twitch to
truly verify someone's real age anyone
at any age can make an account for
themselves as a result Predators have
been using this flaw to find track and
exploit underage users this has almost
always been a problem but since the
pandemic teens and children have been
online for almost double the amount of
time the national Center of missing and
exploited children found that reports of
child abuse on Twitch has increased by
over a thousand percent twitch has
commented on the situation claiming that
they have been working towards a
solution while also pointing out that
they're not the only platform that deals
with this issue and it is true YouTube
and Tick Tock both struggle with this
issue as well but like the report says
twitch allows for these children to be
exploited in real time on top of that to
go live on these other platforms there
are certain requirements you need to
meet the most notable being that you
need a thousand followers to go live on
Tick Tock and 50 subscribers to go live
on YouTube that not only makes it more
difficult to go live but for child
accounts that do amass a following it
gives the platform and law enforcement
more time to show shut them down as it
currently stands to go live on Twitch
you just need to be 13 or older which
already seems like a problem since 13
years old is still very much a child but
regardless of what that number is it
might be futile getting past an age
check isn't exactly difficult to do
which makes finding a solution more
complicated now twitch does have
structures in place both employees and
AI algorithms to help remove children
from the platform when it's obvious
twitch has also been working with the
national Center for missing or exploited
children and law enforcement the hope is
to not just shut down these underage
streamers but potentially expose entire
networks of these Predators the
unfortunate reality is new accounts are
created faster than the situation could
be handled the researcher provided the
evidence they gathered to Twitch and in
response the chief product officer Tom
really had this to say even one single
instance of grooming is abhorrent to us
and if it's valid the data you reference
demonstrates that we are not offering
the level of protection we strive for
yet which is deeply upsetting holding
twitch accountable for combating this
issue is crucial but it's not the only
thing we can do like many issues that
involve young children the best thing
that we can do is educate it is a tale
as old as time but if you have young
family members or can speak to their
Guardians try and explain the dangers of
live streaming after all live streaming
is a relatively new form of posting
online so it's likely that parents
aren't educated enough on the topic now
with this investigation it is likely
just the beginning given the gravity and
complexity of the situation so if there
are any updates we'll be sure to keep
you all informed
[Music]
thank you
foreign